non je vais faire le tour des boutiques
si je fais sur quelque chose pourquoi
pas mais je pense qu'il y aura pas de
budget spécial n'ont pour l'instant
aucun budget je viens la découverte je
te demande de parly 2 pas de budget
précis mais une curiosité pour ce nouvel
espace de parly 2 inauguré fin novembre
16 nouvelles boutiques se préparent pour
leurs premières soldes d'hiver cette
marque de bijoux a fêté sa première
ouverture en centre commercial
alors c'est vrai qu'on attend beaucoup
de monde donc on a préparé une liste à
fait importante en fait de bijoux en
forme de fourchettes de prix et on a
renforcé notre effectif on a prévu
quatre personnes demain sachant qu'en
habituellement on a deux trois personnes
dont on a prévu 4 et peut-être une
cinquième personne en renfort ce besoin
en face même constat pour cette enseigne
née sur internet
donc là toutes les équipes sont affairés
à préparer donc ce que nous avons reçu
en termes de matériel pour les soldes
nous avons une équipe assez complète sur
la nationale est la boutique de paris
donc pas de refaire un objectif en
revanche par contre nous avons des
plages horaires un peu plus large
ouverture donc les équipes seront
présents un peu plus souvent est un peu
de renfort également de la part de nos
stagiaires du siège qui viennent
demain pour la préparation des soldes le
responsable mis sur une augmentation de
30 à 50% des ventes à cette période
un objectif que s'est également fixé le
centre commercial
demain mercredi 10 janvier nous espérons
accueillir quarante cinq mille visiteurs
c'est 40% de plus car à mercredi
habituel et nous avons écrit un objectif
de plus 15% par rapport aux mêmes
mercredi des soldes de l'année dernière
mercredi des sols 2017 selon l'ifop les
français ont prévu de dépenser en
moyenne 195 euros un budget quasi
équivalent à celui de l'hiver dernier